who is never wrong
[Laughter]
are you even in quarantine if your kids
don't crash your zooms tick tocks phone
calls
you name it my apologies
well that's just what happened to tom
brady and giselle bunchen
who is never wrong
[Laughter]
the model launched her tick tock account
on tuesday with a cute couples challenge
but what they didn't know was that their
10 year old son benjamin was getting in
on the fun
too who apologizes first after a fight
who is the funny one
that's tom and giselle sitting on a
couch answering questions about each
other with their eyes closed
who's more patient who eats more
and that that's ben hiding behind the
couch
offering up his own answers who is a
better singer
okay so they don't agree on all the
answers but
they do agree on some things who said i
love you first
who is more stubborn oh it's
healthier yeah
tom told that to e.t in 2016 too
okay between the two of you which one of
you has the stricter diet
i think probably her yeah i think she's
very disciplined the power couple also
has a seven-year-old daughter vivian
and the nfl star also shares a son jack
with his ex
bridget moynihan you know it's a great
part of my life in 2015
tom opened up to e.t about his wife and
being a dad to his three kiddos
she's my best friend so i think he just
uh you know we spend as much time as we
can together
and you know it's a busy life we have
and you know with three kids they're
just the biggest blessing and
my life i'm sure all the parents out
there and
yeah not a day goes by where you don't
laugh and smile at something that they
do
point and case
[Laughter]
and they aren't the only celebs having
their videos crashed by their little
ones
yeah say hi
hello hello say bye bye okay
travis scott and kylie jenner's baby
girl stormy totally interrupted her
dad's insta live
with the hamburger yeah say hi
hi say hi
i don't know it's live and kim
kardashian who's quarantined with her
hubby kanye west and therefore kids
straight up hid in the guest room to try
and film a makeup tutorial
north can i please just do my little
tutorial obviously the answer is no guys
it's all i want to do is one little fun
thing for myself
oh then there was this it's kim
kardashian west and i just
wanted to talk to you and northwest
um have a serious conversation with you
guys about social distancing
we have to start to train ourselves
you went outside in your backyard and
that's totally fine kim filmed a psa
encouraging fans to stay home but again
north wanted in on the action can you
not jump on the bed
give me like two seconds to seriously do
this